- We're in the MoMA stores looking at
the symbolic representation in 1913
of industrial progress and technology
by Ludwig Hohlwein.
Who was based in Munich
and was at the forefront
of a movement known as the Plakatstil,
which gave prominence to
the product being advertised
using the most economic
of means and colors.
You can see how he's really exploited
the tonalities of the
sea and sky to create
this dramatic composition
of interlocking shapes.
It's a poster lithographically
printed in Munich
and it advertises the machine
tools produced by Schiess.
Schiess were the main supplier
for the great government
Navy shipyards in Germany.
And they were based in Dusseldorf,
the industrial heartland.
In this image, Hohlwein has concentrated
on the mysterious and stealthy presence
of a submarine in the background.
And in the foreground,
the machine tools that were
produced by the client.
With the simplest of means
Hohlwein has communicated
the merger of sky and sea
and the stealthy power
of this innovative U-boat
which was to play a key
role in the First World War.
In fact, only two years later,
in 1915 it was a U-boat
responsible for sinking the Lusitania,
that directly provoked the
engagement of the United States
in the First World War.
(gentle music)